[Music]
customs and border protection reportedly
flagging a small number of afghan
refugees for concern during their
vetting at military bases around the
world representatives from the
department of homeland security fbi and
the state department held a phone call
friday to discuss the screening efforts
let's bring in former acting deputy
secretary for the department of homeland
security ken cuccinelli ken welcome to
the show so i don't know if you just
heard our last segment good morning we
had an interpreter trapped um you know
basically you know
we are fearing for his life but the
frustration for me is that he wasn't
taken out but he's he and other guests
that we've had this weekend have said
many afghans have have been evacuated
who did nothing to help america what the
heck is going on
why why is that happening um and and and
why aren't those people who got out
vetted
to make sure they were actually
prioritized as people who helped america
well there's certainly a lot there
first of all to the first part of your
question the reason people are coming
out who did nothing to help the united
states while others are stuck there
is because this wasn't an orderly
withdrawal this we collapsed our
security perimeter
before we did took those protective
steps that should have been taken first
and this was part of a conditional
withdrawal that had been previously
planned under the last administration
that this administration threw out
apparently just because it was president
trump's plan
and um so that's the simple answer to
why you see this sort of chaotic
situation where people who have done
nothing for the united states are
getting out and actually arriving in the
united states
while people who helped the united
states are now trapped and uh
and being hunted by the taliban so and i
would also note for these people coming
here being brought here so quickly look
the vetting process is hard
it's especially hard
in collapsed governations with collapsed
governments like this one this is an 18
to 24 month process with 14 different
steps and their supposedly doing it
which they're not in days and i would
tell you
it hasn't been reported anywhere they've
set up as i understand it a dhs task
force headed by a guy named john
lafferty he is a career official who was
removed by me
from his asylum position because he was
basically conducting his own
uh efforts inconsistent with the
administration and with he would
literally change final documents before
they would go out
uh in my view to set traps for us so
that's who they have leading this they
have a radical deep stater
leading this effort for dhs the the
quality of the vetting has gone through
the floor
yeah of course i mean this is why
well that's why we had such a backlog of
interpreters you know all year you know
we've been you know pete seth has been
trying to shine light on this to
expedite it and the state department has
said it takes time but all of a sudden
it doesn't take time and i'm wondering
ken and i don't have a lot of time left
why have they not been placed in other
countries where we can wait for them to
be properly vetted before being brought
here and by the way probably less
culture shock for a lot of them if
they're in some middle east country
that's an ally of ours
well there you go thinking logically i
mean there is a worldwide consensus of
how to deal with refugee issues and it's
regionally you and the united states has
provided a lot of money all around the
world and we continue to do so to help
resettle people close to their home for
all the reasons you just cite very
intelligent reasons and that's why we do
that
why they're rushing this really skipping
the vetting for many of these people for
the purpose of bringing them in i'm not
i'm not entirely sure other than that it
fits the open borders mentality on
immigration in general it's just break
the doors down and bring anybody in well
it'll be we might have that answer of
why they're doing it when we figure out
where they end up settling them um
politically speaking so thank you ken
really appreciate that
good to be with you good to be with you
too